a lot of streams of Paso a lot has
changed one thing's for sure I'm still
the fluffy guy and I say full of because
that is the politically correct term for
those of you that don't remember I used
to say that there were five levels of
madness reason why I say used to say is
because now there are six I'm at the new
one in Las Cruces the original five
levels are big healthy husky fluffy and
damn people ask what could be bigger
than diet the new levels called
oh hell
[Applause]
what's the difference you're still
willing to work with level five example
if you're on an elevator and you're with
your friend and this really big guy gets
on and you and your friend look at each
other and you're like dude but you still
let the big guy ride your elevator
that's the difference level six you see
walking towards your elevator that's the
difference the guy that I met was six
foot eight six hundred and fourteen
pounds and he was offended at my show
not by anything that I said but because
of the fact that now at the shows I
started selling t-shirts and apparently
I didn't have his size
keep in mind I go all the way up to 5x
on the t-shirts and he was like you
don't have my size I was like dude I
didn't know they made you
I have up to 5x I don't have a picture
of a dinosaur on the back of the tag
enough I had to tell you guys Trevor
Noah has been on the road with my Athena
and I for like I said the last 4 months
and I he's like he's a great friend and
a funny funny man and any of the stories
you guys might have heard about us in
the past and the practical jokes they've
all been true especially when a new guy
shows up you know Trevor's a cool dude
you guys but we couldn't wait to have
fun with him so let me tell you a quick
story we were doing a show in a city
called Eagle Pass in the state of Texas
now
that's something he knows in the house
what's up you far from home coño
so anyway
we're doing a show out in Eagle Pass
Texas now I have a friend of mine named
Rick Gutierrez who's also a comic who
was on last season who lives in San
Antonio Texas which is about an hour or
so away from Eagle Pass he bought a new
car and he drove from Eagle Pass I'm
sorry from San Antonio to Eagle Pass to
meet up with us for a show that night
after the show was over he says hey man
he goes you want to leave a little bit
early and we'll take my car and you can
drive it and the guys can catch up with
us tomorrow in the tour bus so I'm like
cool let's take off so I tell my teen
and Trevor and the rest of the guys I'll
see you guys tomorrow night I'm leaving
with Rick so we get in Rick's car and I
get to drive we head it to San Antonio
about 30 minutes into the drive we start
seeing flashing lights on the side of
the freeway and then a big sign that
comes up and it says immigration
checkpoint ahead don't worry this story
ends differently
so anyways I still get nervous you know
I'm driving and I pull up to the line
I'm sitting and I'm just I'm just
waiting for the officer to say something
that's gonna annoy the hell out of me
so I'm just waiting and here comes the
officer and when he saw me he said Oh
and when I heard that in my mind I was
like I'm not going to jail
so do what are you doing here I said
well we have a show tomorrow night in
San Antonio we're just passing through
where's your tour bus I said well my
tour bus is back in Eagle Pass with the
other guys because can we take a picture
I go what about you no cars coming goes
there hasn't been a car here in hours so
we get out of the car we take some
pictures with the immigration officer in
the bog you know we get back inside he
says thank you so much for taking the
picture with me I really appreciate it
man we're just bored right now I will
really you guys are bored
yeah we're bored I said well my tour bus
is gonna be past and through here in
about two hours
and I says we have a new guy on the bus
was from South Africa and he's he's been
bragging about his immigration status
and how he never has problems with
customs or immigration because all of
his paperwork is always an order I'm
just saying you know if you're bored
next morning you guys I get a text from
Trevor okay you see how cool and calm he
is that takes sounded mad I just look at
and it said you're a dick
I couldn't get to Trevor fast enough to
hear the story right
so my Depina and I we pull up to the
theater and he and he already told me in
the car they do Trevor's man I'm like I
see traveling like Prairie okay and he
just went off Gabriel it was insanity I
tell you it was insanity they pulled me
off the tool bus like I was a common
criminal I wasn't wearing any pants they
took away my passport my cell phone all
of my money they stuck me in a jail cell
with other criminals don't you have
anything to say I said dude you said you
wanted to be black
Crocodile Hunter I give him I give him a
lot of love a lot of credit but you know
people go it's such a loss to the nature
community you know he taught us so much
about nature and I got Madeline I heard
this lady on TV saying that he taught us
a lot about nature and it was like no he
don't really teach a lot about nature if
you want to learn about nature you watch
Discovery Channel or one of these you
know nature programs where they have a
guy on safari and he's studying from
afar crooked a hundred and all come on
every episode
hey all you doing look over there right
there it's a tiger
and Tiger weighs 800 pounds and it could
kill a man in ten seconds I'm gonna
touch it
[Music]
boy he's anger next episode yeah that's
a king cobra the most venomous snork and
all the playing go on boy no I'm dead
I'm gonna pick it up
if he really wanted people to think he
was out there man America we should have
borrowed him and sent him to Iraq with
no gun just a camera crew you imagine
how bad that would have freaked out the
enemy you know you're freaking a soldier
working for al-qaeda and you're out
there you know oh good good people came
to me to get the food and he's walking
towards him wearing shorts
no good food go the parolee can and he's
walking up to him I look over there
that's an arcade of Mumbai there rackin
soldier one of the most dangerous
creatures in all the planet one push of
a button and I'm gone I'm gonna poke him
with a stick
[Applause]
but this is great man we've just been
touring going all over the place and it
feels good to be somewhere for this long
yeah usually it's just what you know
every day we're going somewhere like
Vegas was the last stop right for the
big fight yeah oh yeah we were there for
that fight either me or Nadia I gotta
tell you guys something though for me
the most entertaining thing about that
fight was was the interviews the
interviews leading up to the big fight
you know especially the ones in Spanish
because the interviews in Spanish those
guys get down here I mean it's intense
the guy comes out estamos aqui on ESPN
des portes estamos con Canelo Canelo
please por favor
como vas la pelea contra Mayweather and
then Canelo sounded hardcore and cool
and bad he's like well no Mira la we're
gonna kill you look at the work on
letter H I gotta pee so he's have a
Maria oh my god it was like such an
intense interview and I wish they would
let the guy just do interviews in
Spanish do not make a guy who does not
speak English well do interviews in
English because in English she doesn't
sound intimidating at all hey over here
with our Canelo Alvarez for ESPN sports
Canelo can you tell us what's gonna
happen what's your strategy against
Mayweather
[Applause]
when
I ain't going to hit him like this and
then I'm going to hit him like this and
he's going to come on so the circus
mccurdy going to fall and a tan tan is
like a
since you're quite be aficionado here
what can people do to spice up their
life toys hey come on you can only go so
far with what you got hey yogi when it
yogi but he says toys he doesn't me like
transformers he's like and he's like
bringing stuff to the room your
relationship looks fairly fresh it looks
like you guys just got together you're
still touching each other which is
really cool but not everybody's at night
and not everybody can handle toys no no
no not every what everybody's not
everybody's ready for toys no no no but
if you are you know it doesn't hurt to
go to the shop like you took me to the
sex shop the other day
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me dirty like him let me tell you
guys what happened okay I did not take
him to a sex shop okay the sex shop just
happened to be in the same parking lot
as his restaurant we went to go eat it
okay here's what happened we went to go
eat at this place it was amazing we walk
outside and I'm starved Martine stuff
and he goes ain't look what's next door
oh yeah big deal dude you know it's this
place in Dallas Texas called condom
cents which is an amazing catchy name
for a you know a place like that here I
mean and I goes let's go check it out I
go dude I'm good bro
and he goes man it's freaking hot and I
go oh let's get in the car in the car
wouldn't start and we're freaking
burning up so I'm like I bet you
anything there's good a/c in that you
know in that shop let's go over there
and I get closer and I start getting
recognized in the wind I'm like I'm not
going in there my peoples come on go
with me like on great so we walk inside
and as soon as we walk into this shop
that freakin little sensor at the board
you know in my head I hear pervert
yogi I wasn't feeling it on IR you know
why I don't need anybody taking pictures
of me in this type of place so I tell my
PA per I'm out I'll be outside and he
goes come on broke up with me I said
dude man this is not cool
then this guy leans over the counter and
he sees my teen and I stand in there and
he goes get in here you're chill get any
air it's a party couples only and I'm
like oh my god might think he thinks
were gay I said I'm going outside and
then my teen yells at me go with me and
I'm like great he's yelling at me that
makes me the [ __ ]
now I'm stuck now I'm stuck with his
smoke we walk into this shop and I'm not
about to start walking up to the you
know the stuff that's in there next to
him so that he can look at it and have
the guy think oh that's what he's gonna
use on the big guy he'll know so like my
Athene go do your thing and I just went
to go find some neutral corner to just
hang out and and it might be funny by
the way bro when you're looking at toys
he kills me he does it just look at it
go yeah I want that he actually takes
the time to grab something turn it
around take off his glasses and read
what it does like medication over for he
reads it now oh this one only takes two
batteries right meanwhile I'm in this
other part of the store where they sell
these uh I don't even want to call them
toys they're more like tools yogi like
straight up like devices you know I saw
some stuff in this store you guys that
I'm like why would anyone physically try
to do that to themselves you know like
one thing I saw was from the floor about
this high and I'm like why who could
handle something like that it didn't
even have batteries it didn't have a
cord for the wall this sucker had a
string on the side one of those you know
ladies we don't have that we don't have
that we can't go to the house tonight
babe you ready you ready hold on here we
go
[Applause]
[Music]
you can't get it started you gotta call
a friend to come jump you a year ago I
got to do a movie called Magic Mike and
I couldn't really promote it cuz you
know
well not for kids anyway you know hey
kids go tell your parents to take you to
see you if that fool Pacino yeah so I
couldn't do that and then you know a few
months later I went from an r-rated film
about male strippers to a Disney film
called planes and to do yeah to do a
Disney film you guys is amazing because
you cannot work for a bigger company
than Disney you know you work for Disney
no seriously you work for Disney it's
like a relationship because before I
work for Disney no one wanted to work
with me now all of a sudden you get a
hold of a good one and everyone is
calling you know Nickelodeon was calling
Fox and sports and in Cartoon Network
and Disney makes you feel very
comfortable they let you know right away
Gabriel you have nothing to worry about
Disney is going to take really good care
of your really good care of you
and then nickelodeon called and said
we'll do things Disney won't
I was like whoa hello Nickelodeon so
there I go cheating on business go to
Nickelodeon Studios in Burbank because
they want to pitch me a cartoon and to
get a show pitch to you is very
different than auditioning I walk in and
the director comes out and she was
really cool she's like let me just cut
to the chase this is a special cartoon
here in Nickelodeon it's about a little
toy car this toy car has a bunch of
other little friends that are also toy
cars each toy car has its own individual
personality there's the happy car
there's sad car there's crazy car and
one of these toy cars we need to be a
little different and in Hollywood when
they say different they mean Mexican
that's that's what they don't ever tell
you that because there's a little
politically incorrect you know we want
you to play it no no no so what they do
is they give you a series of suggestive
words to let you know the type of
direction they want you to take a
certain character so they walked me into
a sound room they closed the door they
put me in front of a podium with a
microphone and a script and they gave me
the headphones I'd put them on and then
the director goes behind the glass and
she starts to talk to me through a PA
system and she's like okay listen
Gabriel if you could just read the top
line we're gonna figure this character
out and they were gonna take it from
there okay whatever your attic so the
line that I'm supposed to read is hey
guys I can't believe we're all here so
I'm like I got this here we go I don't
this is Gabriel Iglesias take one hey
guys I can't believe that we're all here
okay listen that's really good really
really good if you could just do me a
favor and give me a little spice
that would be super as soon as I heard
her say spice I'm like oh my god they
want me to play it like a gardener now I
realize I messed up so I'm like ah here
we go
this is Gabriel let's just take two hey
guys I cannot believe that we are all
here okay listen you sound really
unenthusiastic if you could do me a
favor and give me more energy and double
the spice I'm talking muy caliente okay
whenever you're ready this is Gabriel
Iglesias take three okay listen we know
you do sound effects in your show can
you give us a sound effect for a toy car
I'm like toy car I got this no problem
here we go
can you put spice on that they want me
to put an accent on a sound effect I'm
frustrated I don't know what to do I'm
like I don't know room
can you give us anything else I am so
frustrated I'm so annoyed I'm so ready
to walk I just grab the microphone and I
do this just as I'm about to take off my
headphones she looks at me she says
perfect Disneyland I love Disneyland but
they're not fluffy friendly you're not
man they care about safety you know it
sucks cuz I can have a one bar one bar
I'm cool but now they got the whole you
know you're fluffy one of those is not
gonna lock your try people are in line
you'll get
once I might to the trip on my buddy
Monde all right big guy another big guy
and I went with him cuz his family you
know they decided to go and he didn't
want to be the only one hanging up by
the stores so we're hanging out at the
end of the day my buddy mondo goes dude
we should get on a ride I go which one
we can't get on another do or - there he
goes there's a ride here at Disney man
it's called Splash Mountain I go what is
that he goes just a log and you get
inside the log and it goes uphill Goes
Down makes a splash no seat belt
no cool bar you just get in and go no
shita no so we get in line for all
pumped up and I see people getting off
the ride with these little note cards I
go what are those he goes oh they take a
photo of you when you go downhill okay
cool so we get to the front of the line
and then we have to deal with the lady
with the headset the lady who takes you
drive way too serious okay how many
people for up to here to here how many
five okay three there to there we go to
the front how many people who cares we
get our own boat right we take off we're
splishing and splashing like little kids
three minutes go by the moment of truth
we get to the hill right
[Music]
[Applause]
my buddy mondo turns around he says dude
let's flash the camera
I said you're stupid soon as a little
rich we are soaking wet we go to buy the
picture and there's a lady behind the
counter with her hand on the screen and
I asked my buddy mondo I said bro
what port are we he says when you do
discovering 22 goes all we better sneak
out of here oh yeah we're gonna sneak
out we get past the picture girl but
then we get stopped like Disney security
and you have not lived until you've been
stopped by a freaky man wearing a badge
in the shape of a mouse
this guy was like hold on a second man
move your hand away from the screen you
guys see what I see here that's a
disgrace to this spark we can't believe
anyone could take such a photo my
question to you guys do you recognize
the two big women in this picture
[Applause]
and it wasn't until we walked over to
this photo that my buddy Armando and I
realized something about ourselves and
that is that when two full-grown fluffy
men are going downhill at a 45 degree
angle let no shirts on going like this
we both look like sexy [ __ ] how do
you come up with your material Gabriel
how do you come up with the things
you're gonna say things happen to me and
then I instead of just going to a shrink
or something
I suck it up and I come up here like
when I did the joke about the frickin
Volkswagen I really used to own a
Volkswagen I didn't just go let me see
if this is funny I had a book sayin no I
lived it people go why do you wear
Hawaiian shirts I've always worn
Hawaiian shirts bottom line is simple
why do I wear them because they fit
they're colorful and I'm sorry when you
wear a Hawaiian shirt and you're living
in the ghetto people don't think you're
up to no good you're not a gang member
wearing a Hawaiian shirt nobody's gonna
take you serious you know were you from
Honolulu
you can't be hard and colorful no way
man I believe me I've had my encounters
I had a little encounter one time on a
plane some guy was getting a little
weird
uh-uh no more from me every time I get
on a plane there's always drama always
one time I'm flying to Florida and our
plane got hit by lightning uh-huh
the plane dropped 600 feet straight down
that's better than any ride you've ever
been on
I don't care who you are you could have
been freaking doing 20 years in prison
you killed a hundred people you can be
the baddest toughest dude ever when
you're in a plane and it just drops out
of the sky
I was gay for five seconds
all the brought back Mexican yes I was
I don't mind I love you guys trust me
you guys make it possible for me to have
an incredible life and take care of my
family look I'm all for it
not a problem trust me right now it's so
crazy cuz I'm still adjusting to people
walking up to me I'm checking into the
hotel and they already knew me which is
crazy I go like ah hi I'm checking in
here's your key sir but we know it's you
sir I think that's awesome
I needed that like six years ago one
time I was trying to check into a hotel
in Chicago at one o'clock in the morning
because I missed my flight nobody's at
the front desk just a little bell and a
sign that said ring for service so there
I am all of a sudden I heard this
[Applause]
[Music]
okay what's your name my name is Gabriel
Iglesias
yes yes okay okay
vgl no no it's the girls just with an
eye what but you're Iglesias you lazy
lazy it's delicious for an iron whatever
you say is your damn name okay you know
it's bad for you oh this is my grandmama
need to be a honey you go smoking okay I
found you in the system I got you for
two nights full size bed non-smoking I
requested a queen-size bed and you would
have got a queen if you'd have been here
yesterday but it's tomorrow and you're
looking I'm talking to you this is what
I am
what's the ice and salt I need a bigger
bed
grab a seat is Nacho Libre is tripping
oh yeah drinking here in town you gotta
be careful oh man cuz some people can
handle alcohol you know who you are so
people can you have no clue guys
especially you know how it goes we get
loaded we turn into one of three people
right
we're either the I love you guy I hate
you guy or the mere guy you know the guy
right
I know cuz that's me oh my god I can't
handle alcohol people when they get
drunk they say things they don't mean
and you know what I'm drunk you hear
something like I'm going running
you better cut me off
oh hell yeah man and when I drink I only
drink like regular alcohol
I don't do beer beer just doesn't know
beer makes me talk to my bunny I don't
like that I get drunk on beer I get
weird
[Music]
[Applause]
I was saying you just gotta be careful
you know and if you're gonna drink and
you're thinking about driving don't do
it and all it's not a good idea cuz like
I say you know when you're drunk you
know when you're drunk you're doing laps
in the parking lot you can't find the
exit hello some of you make it out to
the streets you don't want you're drunk
you're like you know you know if you
hear if you hear the magical sound one
of two things will pop on your head
either one I'm okay I'm fine I can eat
this
or two
I gotta let you go babe I wanna go to
jail again if you can make the police
laugh you have a chance if you do get
pulled over for drunk okay pull over as
slowly and as safely as you can get over
here now
if you know for a fact that you are
gonna go to jail okay you ready I'm gone
have a little fun I don't mean take off
in a high-speed pursuit do that cuz
you're not gonna get very far I mean if
you're drunk you know you're gonna go to
jail hell and you have tinted windows
have a little extra fun take off your
seatbelt jump over to the passenger side
throw your seatbelt back on and just
wait for the cop
[Applause]
you have no idea how bad you're gonna
throw his hands off you guys he's gonna
come over to the driver's side with a
flashlight
you're sitting there and he was here a
second ago
I don't know he went
what mid-drive oh hell no [ __ ] up
[Applause]